♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A BOY DRESSED AS A
GIRL IS ACCUSED OF RAPING A GIRL
IN THE BATHROOM AT THEIR SCHOOL.
THE BOY HAS JUST BEEN FOUND
GUILTY OF A JUDGE PER THE FATHER
OF THE GIRL WHO WAS RAPED -- THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF LOUDOUN COUNTY
SCHOOLS, GUY CALLED SCOTT
ZIEGLER SAID WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RECORDS OF ASSAULTS INCLUDING IN
OUR RESTROOMS BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T BE BOTHERED TO KEEP
TRACK.
SCHOOLS WALKED OUT AND PROTEST,
WITH THE DAILY WIRE, HE BROKE
THIS STORY AND DESERVES THE
CREDIT FOR IT.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT WITH AN
UPDATE APPEARED LOW, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS STORY IS
STOMACH CHURNING.
TELL US WHERE WE ARE, PLEASE.
>> YESTERDAY THE KID WAS
CONVICTED ON BOTH ASSAULTS.
THE FIRST ONE HAPPENED IN A
BATHROOM WHERE HE WAS CONVICTED
OF RAPE IN THE SECOND ONE WHERE
THE SCHOOL DIDN'T TELL ANYONE IT
HAPPENED AND HE WAS TRANSFERRED
AND HE WAS ARRESTED ON
OCTOBER 6TH.
I BROKE THAT STORY ON YOUR STORE
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND IN THE
DAILY WIRE IN MOST OF THE MEDIA
LARGELY IGNORED IT BECAUSE THEY
SAID IT WAS UNSUBSTANTIATED.
TWO DAYS AGO BARACK OBAMA
ALLUDED TO IT WHILE CAMPAIGNING,
CALLING IT PHONY RIGHT WING
OUTRAGE.
YESTERDAY, EVERYTHING THAT WAS
SUBSTANTIATED IN COURT INCLUDING
A BAZAAR DETAILED THAT THE FACT
THAT THIS KID WAS WEARING A
SKIRT IS ACTUALLY CENTRAL TO HIS
DEFENSE.
HE CLAIMED HIS WRISTWATCH GOT
CAUGHT ON THE SKIRT HE WAS
WEARING WHILE HANGING OUT IN THE
GIRLS BATHROOM AND THAT CAUSED
INADVERTENT SEXUAL CONTACT TO
OCCUR.
>> Tucker: BARACK OBAMA WHO IS
REALLY A HEARTLESS MONSTER AND
I'M GLAD THAT'S CLEAR TO
EVERYONE NOW DESCRIBES THE RAPE
OF A CHILD HAS PHONY RIGHT WING
OUTRAGE?
>> THIS IS WHAT COME HE'S
TALKING ABOUT PARENTS BEING UP
IN ARMS IN VIRGINIA AND
BASICALLY CLAIMING IT IS ALL
CULTURAL WAR STUFF.
FIRST OF ALL, NEVER REALLY CARED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS IS
TRANSGENDER.
THE BIGGER ISSUE IS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
PRIORITIES AS PARENTS AND THAT
IS REALLY WHAT HE HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD WITH, SAYING HE
DOESN'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD BE
TELLING SCHOOLS WHAT TO TEACH,
THE HEAD OF THE TEACHERS UNION
SAID SOMETHING SIMILAR THIS
WEEK.
WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE ROLE AND
THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO THINK THEY
DON'T HAVE ONE.
THESE ARE OUR KIDS, WE WILL
RAISE THEM IN OUR SCHOOLS.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A TOTAL
HOAX.
THIS GUY WHO WAS ARRESTED, HE
LOOKS LIKE A BLUE-COLLAR GUY, HE
IS ANGRY AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, THEY THOUGHT IT WAS A
BIGOT, MAYBE OPPOSED TO MASKS.
YOU CAN HEAR HIS WIFE SCREAMING
AT THE END AS HER HUSBAND IS
HAULED AWAY IN HANDCUFFS, MY
DAUGHTER WAS RAPED IN SCHOOL AND
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
NO ONE ASKED THIS GUY WHY HE WAS
MAD.
WE ALSO FOUND OUT THIS WEEK THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE WORKED WITH THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION TO WRITE THE LETTER
THAT CALLED THIS GUY AND OTHER
PARENTS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS,
WHICH THE DOJ THEN USE TO
JUSTIFY FBI INVOLVEMENT.
>> Tucker: SO YOUR DAUGHTER
GET RAPED IN A SCHOOL BATHROOM
IN THE SCHOOL DOESN'T EVEN CARE
OR KEEP TRACK OF THE RAPE AND
YOU GET DENOUNCED BY THE
PRESIDENT AND THE DOJ IS A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.